[Música]
poco a poco china acelera su diplomacia
en torno a la guerra por un lado el
máximo diplomático del país wangie
visitó Moscú y se reunió con el
canciller Ruso sergei labrov y con el
presidente Vladimir Putin todo esto en
medio del temor de Washington de que
Beijing comience a enviar armamento a
Ucrania a favor de los rusos por otro
lado el gobierno chino recibió a su
contraparte de Japón para discutir la
seguridad ante sus diferencias en puntos
cruciales como Taiwán para analizar Qué
representan todas estas reuniones nos
acompaña en nuestro estudio en Bogotá
Alejandro Godoy él es consultor
geopolítico docente de posgrados de la
universidad militar y especialista en
temas de Rusia y China bienvenido y
gracias por estar con nosotros Gracias
Claro que sí con todo el gusto bueno
Putin afirmó que las relaciones con
china han alcanzado nuevas fronteras así
lo dijo en la reunión que tuvo con el
máximo diplomático ayer en Moscú y
también afirmó que su homólogo chino
visitará prontamente a Rusia esas nuevas
fronteras pueden llegar a representar
suministro de armas o es tan solo un
temor infundado de Estados Unidos
básicamente lo que encontramos es nuevas
reuniones nuevos bloques pero
adicionalmente recordar tanto Sheen pin
como Putin se han reunido cerca de 30
veces en los últimos seis años y es un
paso más de una alianza estratégica de
la diplomacia entre ellos hace tres años
vimos que lo que llamamos nosotros la
diplomacia de los pandas cuando estuvo
en Moscú Y eso estableció nuevos
compromisos Cuál es el temor de los
Estados Unidos Obviamente el tema de una
alianza estratégica militar eso es lo
que Anthony blinken ha establecido y lo
que es de mayor riesgo no solamente para
los Estados Unidos sino para la
comunidad de países que conforman la
otan y por eso Estados Unidos quizás
está respondiendo también
y advirtió consecuencias reales si
Beijing llegase a respaldar a Rusia en
temas de armamento y todo esto se suma a
los globos aerostáticos que se han
derribado en Canadá y en Estados Unidos
y uno de ellos confirmado que era chino
del cual Washington afirma que era un
globo espía y que china dice que era
simplemente un mecanismo para hacer
investigaciones meteorológicas Hasta qué
punto sin embargo pueden escalar estas
tensiones entre Estados Unidos y China
china establece ese mensaje de los
Globos desde dos puntos de vista el
primero de ellos para decirle a la
comunidad interna de su país nosotros
tenemos presencia Y tenemos poder y a
los Estados Unidos no les tenemos miedo
que es lo que más implica y ese mensaje
en este contexto lo que se dice Bueno
por qué globos y no drones por ejemplo
que es más tecnológico y más efectivo en
ese contexto china también dice no nos
vamos a plegar a que Estados Unidos sea
quien decida Cómo se hacen las
relaciones diplomáticas y la alianza
estratégica que tenemos con
Rusia en este caso particular por eso
Hablamos hoy por hoy de una nueva guerra
fría o Segunda Guerra Fría como lo
estamos utilizando en términos
geopolíticos que esta vez incluiría
china adicionalmente con un poder
militar tan grande que es el segundo
país del mundo que tiene la mayor
inversión en este ámbito y no solo la
relación importa por los términos
militares como usted nos explica sino
que además en 2022
hubo un comercio bilateral de 185 mil
millones de dólares y Putin afirmó que
se espera que este año esa cifra
Hacienda a 200 mil millones de dólares
más allá de lo militar que representaría
esta Unión en lo económico y si se puede
hablar también de una alianza de los
pandas en este en este sector sí la
clave de los 200 mil millones de dólares
se suponía que se iba a dar en el 2024
pero ya se está acelerando que es lo más
relevante a China le interesa mucho el
corredor estratégico que es vladivostok
porque eso le ayudaría a su trazado de
la del proyecto de la nueva ruta de la
seda eso le aligeraría Los costos por un
lado y por el otro también obviamente ya
sabemos la cantidad de commodities de
materias primas que tiene Rusia sobre
todo el petróleo y el gas que es tan
importante y China ya lo dijo hace más
de seis meses lo que le deje comprar
Europa nosotros lo adquirimos entonces
obviamente es una relación económica muy
fuerte por un lado y por el otro también
es
solidificar todo lo que se está viendo
en la estrategia de integración eso es
más relevante es más tenemos otros
jugadores no Además de Rusia Irán
Pakistán lo que complica un bloque muy
fuerte y haría un bloque contra
occidente en este ámbito claro Así es Y
ese bloque no solo va en lo económico
sino de nuevo para volver a los términos
militares y no solo implica Rusia porque
china ayer recibió en Beijing a los
enviados especiales de Japón para la
primera reunión sobre temas de seguridad
que han tenido estos dos países desde
2019 Y es que china el año pasado
aumentó un 7,1% sus gastos en defensa
mientras que Japón prometió duplicar su
el destino económico militar de aquí a
cinco años y la atención se es
principalmente por Taiwán en caso tal de
que china llegase a desplegar una guerra
en Taiwán Usted cree que Los japoneses
intervendrían Qué pasa Japón se ha
plegado a los intereses de los Estados
Unidos en lo que llamamos la alianza
estratégica augus augus en la cual está
no solamente Japón sino también Nueva
Zelanda Australia y el papel hay ambiguo
de la India porque también es un socio
estratégico de China y de Rusia que ha
venido consolidando su relación a nivel
económico Por ende la misma Taiwán ha
dicho nosotros creemos que para el 2024
china podría tratar de intervenir
militarmente a la isla en conclusión si
es muy posible que Japón establezca ese
desarrollo y Por ende por eso también
desde la época anterior vemos desde el
2021 más o menos como Japón trata de
tener cada vez un ejército más fuerte
bueno y El Gran temor de occidente o lo
que ha dicho por lo menos mandatarios
como el presidente estadounidense Joe
biden es que ellos temen que se replique
el ámbito expansionista que Rusia en
Ucrania y que ocurra lo mismo entre
China y Taiwán ustedes ya nos decía se
esperaba o se espera que esto ocurra a
2024 cree que podrá haber un conflicto
en la isla
si o sea si vemos un conflicto en Taiwán
obviamente es quintoplicar lo que hemos
visto en Ucrania porque los jugadores en
Asia Pacífico tienen unos ejércitos
bastante fuertes vemos lógicamente que
se plegarían en una alianza estratégica
unos con china otros con los Estados
Unidos y cuál es el mensaje clave de
China es decir es que están en nuestra
zona de influencia entonces lo que
nosotros necesitamos es sacar a Estados
Unidos de esa relación y recordar cómo
china difunde el mensaje de que Taiwán
es una provincia Rebelde Entonces en ese
sentido Sí sería escalar la atención y
la crisis económica sería 100 veces la
que vemos hoy por hoy Alejandro Godoy
Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en France
24 y este análisis tan interesante de la
geopolítica y la economía gracias
ustedes sigan con nosotros Porque en
minutos volvemos con más noticias aquí
en frases24
[Música]